ich möchte kommunalpolitiker werden und
dafür gibt es sogar extra seminare in
einem 70 grad deswegen muss ich auch ein
bisschen leiser sprechen denn es wollen
ja wahnsinnig viele menschen
kommunalpolitiker bürgermeister als
vorgesetzter der verwaltung mit seinen
weil er ja klar jetzt ist es ja auch so
dass kommunalpolitikern also selbst
kommunalpolitikern immer mehr auch hass
und hetze entgegenschlägt ist das
vielleicht auch eine chance an junge
leute dass man sagt das fast so etwas
wie gangster rapper es ist eine
entwicklung die die haben schon sorgen
gemacht weil das sind ja leute die das
im ehrenamt machen in ihrer freizeit und
die sich dafür stadt einsetzen damit es
vorangeht damit die spielplätze gebaut
werden die schulen in schuss sind und
die anzugehen ist genau so indiskutabel
die polizei rettungsdienst oder feuer
werden zu gehen weil die tun das
damit dieser stadt funktioniert dann
versuche ich es einfach mal selber in
gevelsberg sucht unter anderem die cdu
einen bürgermeisterkandidaten und ich
hab alles dabei was man für den
wahlkampf braucht flyer stifter kondome
denn ich habe ein ziel ich möchte
gevelsberger bürgermeister werden
wir haben aber ich bin vielleicht besser
sie müssten das was sie machen wollen
erklären und sie müssen es den leuten
nahebringen und auch mal im schützenzelt
an der theke stehen und sagen jetzt
zusammen und das mal quatschen was das
problem ist also das ist schon auch ein
fulltime job der nicht von 8 uhr morgens
bis 17 uhr getan ist sondern das
wochenende gehört dazu und abends auch
am kammersberg ich komme aus köln
aber ist ja auch um die ecke gebe zwar
auch aus köln heraus regieren
naja ok also sie würden gar nicht
hinziehen es ist ja eigentlich schon
ungewöhnlich mal gevelsberger recht
kleines ja genau aber köln ist ja
relativ groß wenn man bürgermeister
werden will ist aussehen natürlich auch
wichtig spielt bestimmt auch eine rolle
nehme ich mal an ich habe mir jetzt
extra ein anzug angezogen auch jörg kann
auch eine strategie sein kann auch eine
strategie sein in der tat wenn es jetzt
eher darum geht die leute auch mal im
bierzelt zu begeistern dann wären sie
damit eroberte rest ja ich hab viel auf
studierte ich eigentlich unwichtig
studium studios unwichtig wir sind
genauso dumm wie ein lehrling dennoch
keine daher der lehre und dafür stehe
ich das ist mein motto
genauso wie lehrlinge dies sind genau
das ist mal eine beratungs unterlage der
stadt neuss als beispiel von dezember
das ist eine sitzung das ist eine
sitzung wenn sie vorne aufblättern sehen
sie die tagesordnung die relativ
umfangreich ist also sollte ich alles
kennen als bürgermeister sind natürlich
general fachmann das heißt sie müssen im
wesentlichen wissen was steht drin was
ist denn jetzt wichtig im praktischen
wahlkampf als sie müssten im programm
entwickeln mit dem sie antreten wollen
damit sie sagen das sind meine ziele das
will ich für die stadt erreichen also
große versprechungen einfache
versprechungen die sich einprägen was
ich sehr schnell rechts in versprechen
nicht gehalten werden ich habe überlegt
vielleicht ein casino für gevelsberg zur
wahrung casino u bahn habe ich überlegt
nur bahn
wir haben noch gar nichts wir haben noch
niemals mcdonald's gar nichts mcdonald's
kommt auch so verholt ich sofort rein
ich baue flughafen für gevelsberg
für die flieger wenn ich bürgermeister
von beust wäre dann gibt es das hier
nicht mehr
das sage ich ihnen auch 2020 costa
wählen
sauberkeit nun sein also händeschütteln
ist schon auch wichtiger bestandteil
wenn man eure meister werden putzen hört
dass du sagst und die leute müssten ein
gefühl dafür kriegen der ist das was
will der un ist die sympathie geht's
einfach so sonntag
ich würde den schönen tag schöntag
vogelsberg
ich habe sogar kugelschreiber als
werbemittel als mit trotzdem berlin
das ist bestechung ich mir selber trotz
der widerstände geworden das habe ich
nicht gesagt wie schön ich danke ihnen
und dann sind da noch alles fürs
lebenswerk
ich muss auch in die richtung geworden
[Applaus]